my name is anna sponge i come from
western ukraine from the city of lviv and
now i work in parliament being the
head of the committee on foreign affairs
maidan helped many ukrainians realize
that they are the only
political nation also thanks to the
maidan of the revolution of dignity
a lot of new faces of
people who did not  were connected with the
oligarchs who were not part of
any political project, these are
independent experts from analytical
institutions, civil activists who
began to help the parliament to resume
parliamentarism with new approaches of honest
positions of professional work by
defending the interests of citizens if you
want to live with dignity, you don’t have
to take responsibility and build but
the process of building a country where there will be the
rule of law where there will be strong
institutions anti-corruption
decentralization is a complex and difficult
process and therefore you need to be
patient, but we got this
opportunity to build with our own hands  country
and
for the next 5 10 years to strive
not to lose this historical chance